good morning everyone i do think we are
up and running now
uh i'm leslie shopko our communications
manager
joining me today are faces you have been
seeing over the past several days
our president and ceo bill magnus and
our senior director
of system operations stan woodson
we are not out of the woods yet but we
did make a great amount of
progress overnight and into the morning
hours and so we're here to provide you
an update on the latest grid conditions
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to bill
thank you leslie and good morning as
leslie said
we did make a lot of progress last night
and what that progress
uh was was you know as we've talked
about
we've needed uh in order to get all our
customers back on our demand our load
back on
more generation on the system so that we
could maintain the balance of our
frequency
and keep the grid running uh in a safe
and reliable condition
without these outages in place and in
order to do that we just needed more
generation on the system to provide
supply for the still increased demand
and yesterday we began to see you know
steady increases
of uh and return of a lot of the the
generation that
we uh were not able to use because of uh
issues with the storm
and as that grew we were as as quickly
as
practical and and safe on the system uh
reducing the number of outages that we
were requesting from our transmission
operators who are the ones who
uh implement those outages uh by the end
of the night
uh or i guess i don't know exactly what
time but we were able to
um allow the transmission owners to
bring back
any of the the demand the load that was
part of this original event
when we had to give the really large
instruction
of of load shed um demand reduction
in order to keep the grid safe uh after
the events of
early monday morning uh we've been
working since then to
reduce the number of those outages and
we got to a point where we could do that
very effectively so
all of those were originally part of
that uh load shed order we were able to
tell the companies
please you know go forward and restore
those uh
as you can there's still a lot of work
they have to do to get that
to the customers the restoring the
outages in the field is you know is a
process that they have to undertake
but one that they're all very much
interested
and excited about doing just as we were
excited about making it
available since we don't have to have
those outages at the same level now
as lovely said not out of the woods yet
what do we mean
uh we're still in very cold conditions
so we're still seeing much higher than
normal winter demand uh
and we we're obviously keeping a very
close eye on that but we're seeing uh
today we were able to get over our
morning peak
without taking additional uh actions so
that was good news
we still expect a high cold weather peak
tomorrow tomorrow morning and so we
really feel like we're in a glide path
uh we hope where um those customer
restorations happen if we do
uh hit a bump and have some generation
have to come back off uh we may have to
ask for outages but if we do we believe
they'll be at the level where they could
be rotating outages
not the the larger numbers that we faced
earlier this week
so again very good progress uh
to report um still work to be done but
customers should be seeing
uh you know the light and the heat
coming on who haven't been seeing it
uh since earlier this week on a regular
basis
uh as the transmission operators
take on their process to to put the
power back in place
you want to add okay i guess the one
thing i'd add is that
there are a lot of areas where people
say people should see their power coming
back
on and should have since last night
there may be other areas where
those outages will continue and though
that might do be due
to a variety of reasons part in some
areas you may have uh
you may still be on outage because of
icing conditions that on trees that
brought down power lines so those with
those kind of outages would be more
localized
and but it's going to require crews
going out to actually do the
normal ice thing things that happen
during an ice storm to try to
remove the branches and and get the
service restored that way
may also be areas that are were taken
out of service as a part of the
the energy emergency load shed that
we've now allowed the transmission
owners to
bring back online as soon as they can
but they may have to go out in the field
and do some manual switching and that
kind of thing and so it's going to
require crews going out to do that
as opposed to being able to do it
through computer systems so that may
take a little more time as well
and then we've also just got some large
industrial facilities that are still
offline that voluntarily reduce their
load and so we're going to have to step
those back in in an organized fashion to
make sure we don't put the risk
grid at risk as we do that and
prioritize those
that are most necessary to keep the
system stable and
and provide products back to say
generating units to make sure those
generating units stay
online so we don't kind of work back
into a problem but instead get further
out of it
okay uh well i already see the list of
questions coming in as a reminder if you
do have a question please go ahead and
submit them through the chat
and also if you have my cell phone
number you're welcome to text me your
questions
so uh the first question from the wall
street journal
are there any penalties at all for
generators who were unable to produce
power
does this depend on whether they bid
into the market and agreed to deliver at
a certain time
uh i guess there's there's maybe two
answers
uh and we don't we don't uh
we're not an enforcement entity so we
don't
that's not part of what we do is uh
enforce
those kinds of rules but and those there
are rules from the
north american electric reliability
corporation nerc
uh that apply uh to uh to generation
owners
so if there's anything there that's
that's for the nerve to take a look at
in it in compliance
but the other uh when you talk about
penalties these are not penalties but
uh the way the aircrop market works
the failure to supply when when you have
committed can have very serious
financial consequences when our scarcity
pricing mechanism
is in effect so there's a very strong
financial incentive
and to the extent that uh
generators are not able to to deliver uh
on their commitments
they there's they'll face you know
financial consequences in the
marketplace
uh as well as any potential regulatory
okay next question is from the fort
worth star telegram
can you talk about measures ercot takes
to prioritize critical facilities like
water treatment plants and pump stations
did ercot know fort worth treatment
plants would be caught up in the
rotating outages could that have been
avoided
and what will be done to make sure that
doesn't happen again
well we don't have a role in determining
where the rotating outages are
implemented
uh we tell the transmission owners like
in fort worth would be encore
we need a certain amount of demand
reduced we need load shed
let's say that's 100 megawatts then
encore has a plan that's developed
which includes critical care
designations uh where they want to try
to avoid
uh outages uh so i i don't i don't know
the circumstances of that situation
at all but um uh that would be
where to to look whether there's
something occurred in the implementation
of the
of the load shedding program that had
that impact but i'm not aware of
that particular circumstance
okay next up nbc 5 in dallas
bill five days before the storm you had
a board meeting where you said you were
ready for the cold weather
and that the plant operators had been
notified to get prepared
you seemed unconcerned how was urcot's
assessment of what was coming so far
off well i i didn't mean to convey
unconcerned i think it was the first
thing i mentioned when i started
briefing the board we were
uh in the first stage of providing
notice to
uh the various market participants that
we were going to see we
we thought we were going to see
significant issues and as the week
progressed and the forecast sharpened on
the weather it looked increasingly
uh like we were going to see something
very very significant as we did
but we provided notices out to the
market saying you know be prepared do
what you need to do on february 8th
and the 10th and the 11th we've
worked with the governor's office and
the state operations center
to get the message out uh on saturday
uh in a press conference so we sent out
a conservation message on sunday to tell
people to start to
start conserving sunday night into
monday morning so i think
there was certainly a lot of
communications from us
uh and if i if what i said indicated we
weren't concerned i really was just
trying to notify the board that this is
something we got to keep an eye on
because it's coming at us
uh but we did the all the technical
notifications to the actual folks in the
in the field doing the work
uh i think uh several times
um and with increasing urgency as we saw
what was going on
okay next question is from the
montgomery county gazette
um will customers be seeing an increase
in their energy bills
you know we're not uh in the business
uh the retail energy business
we really can't speak to to customer
bills
we work in the wholesale market we work
with the transmission system
uh but really wouldn't want to speculate
on what individual customers will see
okay the next question in 2011
ercot released a list of those power
plants that went
offline when will ercot be releasing a
similar list
yeah so i'm sure i mean our primary
focus at this point
is to make sure that we now that we've
kind of started to get most of the
load back on we're still focused on
making sure the grid remains stable that
we can step back in these remaining
outages and that's really the focus at
this point
we have in our computer systems of the
list of all those
generators when they went offline when
they came back online if they tripped
again
all of that kind of information is there
and so in the coming
weeks and perhaps months we're going to
be gathering all that data up and
turning it into a
fairly what i expect to be a fairly
massive report and
providing that information out to the
public and uh
so so we will be doing that once we kind
of get through the
immediate problem which is making sure
that we get everybody back up and the
system
uh kind of working as normal again
i just add i think uh in the we have a
special board meeting next week there
are legislative hearings next week
looking into
the event this week so i think we'll
start to get you know a lot of requests
for information
and analysis uh so people can assess uh
the whole event
and uh as dan's describing i mean that's
part of that and i'm sure we'll have a
lot of other
issues that people want to address and
data they need from us so we'll be
gathering that up as we get those
requests
okay next questions are from stephen
dallas you said yesterday you can't
require weatherization who has that
authority
and what is your opinion as to whether
or not weatherization should be
mandatory
well so so the i think i mentioned this
on previous calls that the north
american electric reliability
corporation
is the standard setting body for
reliability with with respect to the
electric power system
and they they regulate transmission
owners they regulate uh
generators and other entities that
operate
in the power system and under the
auspices of the federal energy
regulatory commission
and that standard setting group is
working on a winterization
standard uh and that's an ongoing
process
uh it's not completed yet but that would
be a uh
the most likely uh route for some kind
of regulations like that
um and and that they're a pretty
substantial uh
their their regulatory capability
through burke is is pretty substantial
nationally they can issue
pretty severe fines of a million dollars
per day per occurrence for things and so
you think that that's that's the most
likely way that some kind of regulation
like that might occur
okay the next question is from rudy
koski at fox 7 in austin
central texas seems to have a larger
percentage of outages
compared to the dallas and houston areas
why is that
i think uh you know like we mentioned
there there may be kind of three
categories of consumers that are still
out of service
the the uh the ones that are out one one
that i mentioned was the ones that are
out because of ice damage
i storm damage on distribution system
particularly the wires going out the
neighborhoods and everything
i think we've heard from some areas of
central texas that
that's maybe more severe uh in central
texas than it is in some
other parts of the state um um
you can just imagine oak trees which
live oak trees still have all the leaves
on it you put a bunch of ice on it and
we've seen lots of pictures of that
if those fall on lines then crews have
to go out and and fix those lines
we don't have any specific information
about that
but from what we've amounted
that we've talked to the transmission
owners about uh there may be more in
this area
and that may be part of the part of the
issue because
as as far as the restoration for uh
due to the load shed event that should
have been the restoration of that should
be distributed
evenly across the state and wouldn't
result in any kind of
what your what your question was asking
about
okay the next question is from scott
friedman your winter preparedness
assessment said you were ready to
meet whatever winter peak the state
would see
in hindsight what led to the mistakes
that were made in those assumptions
well so i guess the the the seasonal
assessment of resource adequacy on which
we base that
uses the winner of 2011 which has been
the most severe winter in
in quite a while as the kind of the
faces for the low forecast
um the uh number of outages that are a
suit of trans
generation plants that are assumed in
that assessment are based on like a 95th
percentile of outages that
occur over the last i don't remember how
many years it's based on that's the 95th
percentile
and so i think because of the really
unprecedented nature of this weather
event
the load levels we saw were beyond
the the kind of the 2011 level of load
for one thing uh by several thousand
megawatts
and then on the outage side we were
probably well beyond the
95th percentile of the outages of
generating plants that occurred
that had been experienced historically
during a winter peak type situation
and you know to that point going forward
having seen the extent of this event i
mean certainly it figures into what we
think we'll see
in history uh just as we were measuring
against the most severe
uh system that we had seen in the winter
in texas before
uh this one changes the game uh because
it was you know
so much bigger so much more severe and
we've seen the impact it's had so i
think as we look at
those assessments for the winter season
the future uh what we've
uh what we saw with this storm um
something we
haven't seen anything like this that
certainly goes into our consideration of
what the risks are
okay the next question uh i don't have a
name but when did ercot
first tell governor abbott about the
potential for rolling blackouts and how
did he respond
well we um were convey
we we are in uh the reason i hesitate is
like we're in constant communication
with the public utility commission
uh and uh is our you know liaison uh
there
and so we were um uh providing i think
you know these notices we provided
during the week we
let folks know as we did with mark
participants that these
about the ocn the operating condition
notices
that are the you know sort of the
warning that says get ready uh
so we're providing that information um
and then uh
we participated in the press conference
of governor abbott chairman walker and
craddock
and chief kid saturday uh and
um uh you know expressed our concern
particularly around monday morning and
tuesday morning
uh that we could have rotating outages
uh so i think
uh you know that was a message that was
uh put out in that press conference and
uh we tried to get the
public attention to that and also talked
about on talked about the need for
conservation because we were concerned
about the possibility of rotating
outages so certainly
i mean you know the governor was uh
promoting
caution promoting preparedness on all
fronts
not just for electricity but for roads
for everything else
knowing that this storm was going to be
pretty ferocious
okay the next questions are from the
dallas morning news i'll do
one and then the other why were
blackouts not able to be rolled in the
last few days
is it because the state has too much
critical infrastructure and does this
need to be scaled back
i guess i wouldn't comment on the the
critical infrastructure because again
those
those are determined by our transmission
owners who have the
local plans that they do uh
but the the central problem i think
about the rotating not
being able to do rotating hours
effectively was the amount of
uh demand that we had to reduce uh
was really unprecedented just because of
the the challenges we face with the
weather and with the generation
uh so you know the the transmission
owners
can what they mean by you know rotating
or rolling and an outage is
they it's in one neighborhood or area
for one period and then you lift that
and then you
apply it to another area or neighborhood
but you have to
have some room right and there wasn't
enough
uh there weren't enough places to move
it around uh in order to cover the
amount that we were asking for
so i think that was the central issue i
i wouldn't couldn't really comment on
how the critical infrastructures are
treated in various
transmission owner plans
and the second question was how much of
this regulations
fall to the railroad commission and not
the puc and ercot
uh well the the ercot is overseen
by the public utility commission they
have full authority over
everything we do really the decision we
make uh so they're really the regulatory
authority for us
and then for uh the electric industry
particularly the transmission
owners um the railroad commissions uh
baileywick is more in the natural gas
area
and you know the railroad commission
took steps to assist
getting ready for the storm uh but
assisting in how natural gas was
prioritized
during this period uh of the
weather and so they were dealing with
the natural gas aspects of this and
chairman craddock has been very involved
in uh trying to make sure the gas supply
is is out there and can be used
effectively by the electric generators
and these times we really really need it
uh so i a few answers your question but
i think that's the
sort of the divide is uh natural gas is
over at the railroad commission
i do think that that one of the issues
that we had
not initially in the event when the
generators were kind of coming offline
because of the cold weather
because fundamentally this is a this is
the issue is we had high demand
we also lost a tremendous number of of
generators
on the kind of around midnight on
sunday to monday well it's a tremendous
number of generators
and a lot of those tripped offline
because of cold weather causing those
generators to trip offline we kind of
talked about the
winterization that would be required to
fix those
but we've also then later in the day we
started having problems with having
enough gas to get to some generators we
had there were pressure
issues that were reported to us on gas
and so forth
and fundamentally it seems like the the
problem goes all the way back to the
wellhead well
we had a lot of well heads freezing up
so that things weren't
the gas wasn't able to come out of the
ground and get into the pipes in order
to make it to generation
and also make it to the heat to heat
houses and those kind of things
so one one potential path of
regulation might be to make sure those
wellheads that would help with this
situation from my perspective is
make sure those wellheads don't freeze
up so that we have enough gas in these
kind of cold weather event
okay next question from william joy is
it accurate to say that as of right now
no private customer is on a rotating
outage
uh no i i the reason i say no is
there are still customers that uh need
to be restored
uh so if if what the question means is
that uh there's no one without power due
to an outage
uh the answer is no because as we talked
about at the top the transmission owners
you know we've we've uh allowed the
restoration of sort of all the service
that was part of
the monday uh rotating outage the really
large rotating outage
but that that completion of that takes
some time
uh and so i i don't think it's accurate
to say that
there are no customers that are still
affected uh
until that's fully executed but they're
they're working on it and have been
every time we've released more uh load
and demand
side uh outages for them to to uh
restore their at it you know getting
getting those done
okay the next question is from mark
watson with platts
why do you continue to count virtually
all of the wind and solar
as accounting for about 12 gigawatts of
generation
on forced outage when you are only
expecting to have about six and a half
gigawatts of renewable generation to be
online during this winter's peak
i guess from uh from a it's an
accounting perspective that as we
started into this
we were reporting installed capacity and
we continued to do so
we did have some discussion uh early on
in some of these calls that
that we the amount of wind that was
being produced
at various points in time was actually
even though we had half of the
installed capacity of the wind turbines
that were out of service
the half that were in service were
actually during the kind of
worst part of the event we're actually
producing
more of output than what we counted
upon in our seasonal assessment from the
hopefully
during winter peak type conditions
hey leslie can't hear you
oops i'm sorry i was unused uh okay the
next
question if storm damage is the main
reason for the outages what is
preventing moving us out of the eea
three
well the we're
looking to make sure that we're fully
stabilized
and there are still customers
who are not yet restored as we were
saying that progress in getting them
restored isn't complete
and we feel like as long as there are
still those customers that are
part of a rotating outage we want to
make sure that we
maintain you know the emergency
conditions the other part is
uh we really feel like given the
large nature of the effort to get the
load restored
we want to be sure that we're not you
know moving too quickly moving too fast
out of emergency conditions which give
us some
uh authority opportunities to to act
so we still have that
status in effect but and we want to be
sure that we're clear
of the weather today the weather
tomorrow uh morning peak
um before we move out of it too quickly
so it is it's a conservative
uh decision but one i think given the
still fluid nature of the weather and
and
making sure we've got the generation we
need and we keep it on
we feel like it's prudent to remain in
that status
yeah bill coming off those comments i'm
going to give you this question from
five in san antonio uh snow is falling
again in many areas of texas
how much should people be preparing for
more potential outages
and so there's a there's a there's a i
guess there's two two things
um there's there's is the possibility
that as we've gotten
all the customers uh kind of or not all
the customers but a lot of the customers
turned
back on overnight last night that as
their consumptions
people go back into their houses they
businesses turn back on
now that they've got power back and
those kind of things we may see
a lot of demand and there's also the
potential for
generators to become unavailable right
now that that's
the generation availability is going up
uh and so uh if we if the demand
outstrips the supply again like for the
evening peak today or tomorrow morning
we could have to go back into rotating
outages because of this this power
balance problem
um but as bill said rather than kind of
the opening statement we don't
we would expect that those uh any
outages like that would be limited and
we would be able to rotate them as
opposed to these more extended out
if we if they're required we're
certainly going to try to avoid that
um the the other thing that could happen
with
additional ice and snow and those kind
of things is that that could lead to
more outages from uh
it was just a i call it a normal ice
storm
you know trees falling on power lines
and those kind of things so so there
could be additional outages like that
uh from this but uh hopefully uh not
well and that i mean that the continued
weather conditions like we said at the
top is why we feel like you know we're
reporting a lot of success
uh for customers in texas uh but we're
not ready to
uh say we're finished with this event
because
the weather drove the event the weather
could still drive uh
events on the grid as dan explained
okay i'm gonna circle back to
weatherization plans because i
keep receiving several questions i think
there's confusion about
what is required versus what is
voluntary regarding weatherization plans
dan previously said these were voluntary
but we've also been told that generators
are required to submit them
so are there any requirements for what
must be in these plans
i i think the idea is that there are
mandatory reporting requirements for
to have a plan and report that plan to
the puc
there are not specific uh requirements
as
uh to the extent of you've got to have a
win wind breaks of this type you've got
to have
these kind of boxes around your
instruments you've got to have
this amount of heat traced on your
on your uh of the equipment that needs
that so they're not
specific requirements but those those
are more best practices that are they're
voluntary
so specifics but you do have to have a
plan and there are characteristics that
have to be in that plan
as far as the things that you're
recording that that particular
do you know how many states require
weatherization
that was a follow-up question
i i don't know
okay the next question is from marcy de
luna
electricity was trading at the state max
of nine thousand dollars per megawatt
hour in wholesale markets across the
state wednesday morning
what is the estimated immediate and
long-term cost
to wholesale and retail
i i don't think we're able to really
provide an estimated cost at this point
uh particularly as the event isn't over
that's something i know will be
analyzed in great detail and looked at
by policy makers as well as the folks in
the market
so i don't really feel like i have an
estimate to provide you certainly on the
retail level
there are so many different plans and
arrangements particularly in the
competitive retail areas that we really
can't
speak with any um you know accuracy
certainty about
about dollars around that
okay next question from texas public
radio the feds warned that the texas
grid was
vulnerable to a failure exactly like the
one that happened why was the grid not
prepared
um i'm not i'm not sure what federal
report
uh is is being referenced specifically
to that
uh and as we've you know been explaining
as we go through
uh the event this week um the
fundamental thing we have to do to
protect reliability
is to ensure that there's not a
catastrophic blackout
uh ensure that we get we don't get in a
situation where we're starting the grid
from scratch and power can be out for
indeterminate amounts of time as those
physical components of the grid have to
be restarted and fixed
uh that is the disaster scenario uh
that we have we it's our central job to
avoid as
uh disastrous as this has been um for a
lot of people
and it has been because of the out the
length of the outages and the the
intensity of the weather um the reason
that we took this action was to prevent
uh that kind of uh blackout so
i think as far as urkot maintaining that
level of reliability
we're going to walk away from this very
soon we hope
and have an electric system that works
just like it did last week
because we were able to control the
situation by using these outages
as difficult as they were we are able to
now
if we hadn't controlled them we couldn't
go back and say please put these people
back on
uh if we'd had a blackout so i think at
a fundamental level i think that's
why we took the actions we took uh and
if we hadn't the consequences could have
been much worse
uh so and as far as the you know other
preparations i think as we've been
discussing you know the notices we
provide the information we give to our
market participants
we see events like this uh all the
things we do in our control room to get
ready for
or weather events like this i think
demonstrate
a preparedness to deal with these uh
issues and that's
you know that's what we have been up to
throughout this event is executing on
those procedures and um
as hard as it is to have these outages
out work as hard as we can to
eliminate them as quickly as we can one
of the one of the issues that you know
i've been reading some of the media
reports on this and one of the issues
that i think we're
uh is you know once the regardless of
what could have been done in in the past
to make sure we had more gas supply and
the units were weatherized and those
kind of things
once you got to the point that all these
units have are gone
that's the amount of load we can serve
and and there's nothing ercot can do
at that point except make sure that i
mean there's nothing
can be done from a fit laws or physics
perspective but
you can you can't serve more demands
than that the actions that we took in
in the middle there to actually
institute the rotating outages in a
controlled way
as the generators tripped offline
preserve the integrity of the system as
a whole
uh and and and and allowed us to
transition the load down to where we it
matched with the the
generation in a controlled way but
fundamentally even if we hadn't ordered
those
rotating outages supply and demand we're
going to balance from a physics
perspective and so
by us doing it our operators taking the
actions that they took
in that in the course of that transition
as the units were tripping offline
they preserved the integrity of the
system and actually
facilitated as long as these outages
have been in as hard as they've been for
folks
uh they've allowed us to to transition
back
where we're restoring this a lot quicker
than as they'll keep saying if we had
this kind of
catastrophic much longer term thing if
that transition that occurred in an
uncontrolled way
yeah i think just emphasize the point if
if we were
in uh if we had let physics do the job
you know and it had been totally
uncontrolled we had a blackout
we wouldn't be sitting here talking
about restoration you know today
tomorrow
we would be telling you that we're not
sure when restoration would
would be done because it's such uh a
disastrous event when it occurs
uh and and takes much much much longer
and people are out of power for
you know even longer much longer than
what we're seeing here so
again we feel like having control over
the system and maintaining that is
essential to what we have to commit to
is a grid operator
okay the next question is from argus
media to what extent
is the lack of natural gas supply to
gas-fired plants still causing generator
outages
i don't think i've looked at that this
morning and i apologize for that
to see kind of how much is associated
with that
we've been more working toward how do we
preserve the
ability for the plants that are online
to continue generating
how do we make sure that additional
generators don't trip offline
or or become unavailable because of uh
different a variety of things and so
so that's been our focus at this point
and so i haven't actually looked to see
how what any kind of ratio
or anything like that at this point
okay the next question is from robert at
kprc
are you getting any more specific
details as to what brought down various
generators
um i it's almost the same answer as the
other question we've got we got some
limited uh information in
as generators tripped offline we've
heard some more
things about uh we could be back online
if this happened or that happened
we've been trying to facilitate that as
much as we can
for some of the generation or for the
generators that
bring that up uh but at this point
after the fact we'll go in and do rfis
and that kind of thing together the
specific information as opposed to this
kind of post critique of the entire
event and the event analysis
to make sure that we learn from it and
and the
same things don't happen again yeah and
in that in the
uh time when we're just you know trying
to
work on this priority and getting
customers back
the central thing we need to know from
the generators is not why but
when when is it are you going to come
back you know when is it we can get you
back on the system
and diagnosing the the cause
as dan says something that i think comes
in the post-event analysis that in the
moment
uh what we really need to know is when
will we see you back on the grid
whatever your problem is and so that's
been the primary focus now and needed to
be
because if we had gotten uh bogged down
and a lot of analysis of
you know why someone tripped that
doesn't matter as much to whether we can
get them back on
the grid and you know have them serving
customers
okay uh this is from jack fink at cbs
dallas regarding the nerc
winter standard that is being developed
would
state law have to change in order for
ercot to require better winterization
um if if the so the the nerc standards
uh are generators that
that participate in the or that are
connected
to the uh to any power system are
what are they have to register as
generation
operators in with nerve or with the the
regional entity that's a part of nerve
and so they they have to be registered
and by registering they become beholden
to these standards and have to meet the
standards so if that standard passes
that's the process that would cause them
to be
a part of that and that's that's that's
more under federal law than state law
from a reliability perspective
okay this is uh going back to
the question that mark watson had about
wind
seeking clarification is dan saying the
wind
turbines over produced on what was
expected during this storm
so at the point in time that we were
reporting it i think that's that's the
case
that kind of during that heat can but it
depends on what point during the event
we're talking about
um right now wind is producing 6 500
megawatts or something like that
with the turbines that are are available
uh and and even and which i think is
close to the seasonal amount even
our seasonally expected amount during
peak conditions
even though they're still uh i think the
number was
16 000 megawatts of them that are forced
out
due to icing
okay the the next question was could you
provide an update on the numbers how
much
uh total generation is forced out and
what's the make up between
thermal and wind solar
yeah so the the the the total out at the
as of when we issued the news release
this morning was 40 000 megawatts of
total generation
including the installed capacity of the
wind about 23
500 of that is thermal generation
and the rest is is wind and solar
okay next question is from west
rappaport at nexstar
media group how close was the texas grid
to these catastrophic
blackouts that you have been talking
about we talking seconds minutes hours
days
certainly not days and i don't think
hours uh
you know when we our frequency went to a
level that
if our operators had not acted very
rapidly
uh to change the situation and arrest it
uh
it could it could have very quickly
changed and the reason i
i can't be as specific as seconds or
minutes
is that what was driving this uh
early monday morning sunday night was uh
seeing starting around 11 o'clock or
midnight uh
generation units coming off and then
more coming off in rapid succession as
the storm blew through
so one of the reasons that operators
have to act
uh to arrest the frequency is if they
say well you know let's wait another
minute and see what happens what happens
that next
minute might be three big units come off
and
then you're sunk uh so we were at a
level of frequency which
uh was uh one that needed to be
addressed immediately and that's what
the operators did
so i think you know if we hadn't taken
action it wouldn't have been that we
would have waited a few days and saw
what happened it was
uh seconds and minutes given the amount
of generation that was coming off the
system at the same time that the demand
was
still going uh up significantly so there
is a
system in place where uh uh it's called
under frequency load check that that
where there are what's called relays
there's devices
out across the transmission system that
if the if this power supply imbalance
becomes so severe that the frequency
drops
really fast really far and there's
different levels
that it will these will automatically
shed five percent
and then if it drops further they'll
check 10 and
and if they shed further it'll drop
it'll uh shed an additional 10 percent
so it's about that it's kind of a safety
net that if our
operators don't our operators and the
transmission owner operators aren't able
to shed
load in a controlled way which is what
we did
by choosing which circuits are are taken
out and
rotating through them and those kind of
things the safety net
should protect us for at least up to 25
percent loss of generation
but that's much more of a blunt
instrument it's harder to get the load
back faster
and it's not as controlled as what what
occurred one way or the other
is law of physics
the load is going to match the the
generation
and it's better to do that in a
controlled way like we did
and just let the safety net take it
the next question is from mark chediak
at bloomberg news
how has ercop been able to bring power
back so fast
did wind pick up is this largely from
the reactor coming back
or did it finally get warm enough for
the gas plants to work
so it's a it's a it's a variety of
things uh we've gotten
more generation back online of of
different types
we had more uh like during the afternoon
yesterday we had quite a bit of solar
generation online
so while that solar regeneration was
online we started trying to bring
back a lot of uh the load um
once we started in a very
deliberate manner starting to bring back
uh
and tell the transmission owners please
restore
a thousand megawatts of blood uh they
would go out and do the switching that
it would take to do that
and turn on different uh neighborhoods
that matched up to their share of that
thousand megawatts
and then once they were done we issue a
if we still had enough generation at on
at the time we'd issue a
order to go restore another thousand
megawatts and so we started to pick that
up
after we've done a few of those we
recognized that
we had more generation we had more
generation coming online and
the load that we were restoring per
feeder was less than what we expected
because businesses were shut down and
those kind of things and we realized at
that point that we could start to go
much faster
and so we that's that's really what
happened we started
telling the transmission operators to
restore this is kind of pretty much as
fast as you can because
we were we could keep up with it in
terms of generation
and that's why we were able i think this
was a question earlier that
by midnight last night we had uh told
the transmission owners
basically restore what what you can the
rest of what you can so we've worked
through that in steps
we started going a lot faster in the
late afternoon
and then uh kept going and then by
midnight we had kind of released the
uh to the to the level that they're
they're at at this point
so at this point how would urcot grade
itself during this
crisis please explain what grade and why
texans would like to know
this is from maya shea at abc 13.
you know we're still in the event we're
still
moving through you know the crisis that
was caused by this
uh i i just have to tell you it's a
little early um i will give
a good grade to the operators who took
those actions we just discussed to
prevent
a catastrophic blackout much worse
damage to our system
uh that was the i'd say the most
difficult decision that had to be made
throughout this whole event
uh was to do that rapidly and uh at the
size they did
because of the you know the loss of the
generation that we were seeing and the
increase in the load
so that that fundamental decision i
think was certainly sound
and uh had to be made i think you know
going forward
there's going to be a lot of
investigation assessment you know
examining
you know every step in this process and
and how our response
is uh i really think there will other
people ought to greatest uh you know and
we'll provide the information that's
needed to make those assessments and
uh want to learn from it i mean in the
business we're in we need to constantly
be
learning uh from uh events that we've
had
how to better utilize technology how to
better utilize
other tools to make the job of the
operators
even better so they can have more
options and take advantage of them so
i just say let us get through the event
get customers back on uh and then we can
take a look at
the details of our performance
okay next question uh moving forward
when
or will urcot winterize the system was
this the ultimate
issue this is from wfaa in dallas
i guess i'd say i have to step back and
say that
you know ercot is the uh the traffic cop
on the grid where the the air traffic
controller
managing the the flow of the electricity
we don't own the generation units we
don't own the transmission
uh we're really just managing the
overall uh
transmission system uh and uh
dispatching you know
putting generators on and off the grid
so
winterization is an effort that's going
to be need to be undertaken by those
entities that own the physical assets
out in the field
uh so we i the reason i said is we say
you know when will we winterize
it's really the the owners of the assets
that have to look at winterization best
practices and what are they going to do
to prevent issues like they saw
over the last few days i mean we're
willing to you know
work and help and make sure that those
are
effective and you know happy to work
with any of the industry on that but
it's really not our role to do
winterization
okay the next question is from leticia
miranda with nbc news
can you please address the issue of
electricity surcharges some consumers
have been charged high amounts for
electricity
t-puck said this is a result of a quirk
in urcot's system that has been
corrected can you please explain that
and how will it be corrected
right i've never heard anything about
that
yeah as customer search charges i have
i haven't heard of customer surcharges
related to this
um and we can't really speak to
the the surcharges the en-use customers
get
because and we're working in the
wholesale market and that's
separate in the retail market and we
just we don't have visibility into that
the public utility commission did issue
an order a couple of days ago
they had an emergency meeting to adjust
the wholesale scarcity pricing mechanism
to be sure that it was working
effectively to deliver as much
generation onto the system as possible
during this event
and we were able to to make just a
fix in our software program um
and how it treated uh those scarcity
prices to
implement uh the change that the public
utility commission thought was
appropriate
so as soon as they said they wanted to
make that policy change uh
you know we got right to it and
implemented in our system so it's
reflected in the wholesale
uh price that i know that the public
utility commission did issue an order
about this week
but again the retail surcharges i'm not
sure what the about that issue i'm just
not familiar with it
okay the next question is travis bubenik
with courthouse news
texas lawmaker dan crenshaw made a claim
widely shared on social media that
every natural gas plant stayed online
the downed plants were due to scheduled
maintenance
is that accurate
well i think like we've talked about
earlier there there were a few plants
that were out on scheduled maintenance
but
uh the plants the majority of the plants
that are that this number
that we've been reporting are plants
that went out either
fairly soon before the event because of
natural gas restrictions
uh or some of the icing of the turbines
or that tripped off lime
in the morning and then after the days
afterwards during the event
and the those generators in the
aggregate were
of various fuel types there was wind
generation
there was nuclear generation there was
coal generation there was gas fire
generation
all we have had uh units of each of
those types and and multiple units of
each of those types
i guess except for nuclear uh that
tripped offline
during the event
okay we have a little less than 10
minutes left
so i will try to get through as many
more questions
as i can the next one is from robert
arnold how fragile is the grid right now
are you concerned about plants going
down when more people come back on
yeah so i don't think we're we're not
worried about more plants going down
but cause more consumption uh if we if
just like we did before if we wind up
that if
more consumers you know like tonight
there's a lot more load as people start
turning things back
on as businesses reopen those kind of
things if that exceeds the amount of
available generation
we've said in the news release that we
could it's possible that we if that kind
of situation occurred we could have to
re-implement
rotating outages on a limited basis and
hopefully be able to rotate through
those as opposed to
having the longer term outages that have
happened before
um the uh the the
generation i think we we didn't lose
anywhere near as many plants tripping
offline
yesterday as what had happened for the
previous few days
so so it seems to be the as far as the
stability or the
kind of stability in the availability of
generation
seems to be much better now but one of
the things we're really watching is
making sure that those generators get
what they need
make sure that we're restoring power
back if there if
if there's because icing or something
like that there's there's not power to
natural gas compression stations and
those kind of things make sure we've got
plenty of pressure on the gas system
to continue to uh provide gas to the
electric generation make sure that we
get uh chemicals back to
the plants to make sure that they are uh
you know can uh use the chemicals they
need to keep that electric generation
online
and so that's really our focus right now
uh
but but to make sure that we don't have
additional problems occur that would
take generation offline
but for for what what this happened you
know yesterday afternoon and today we've
seen much less plants kind of tripping
for
weather release reasons or gas reasons
or anything like that so it seems
we've definitely seen an improvement
this is a follow up from platts would
you say that the improvement in
temperatures had as much
or more to do with the elimination of
widespread rolling outages than any
increase
in generation capacity
it probably had a bigger impact
than the availability of generation in
terms of
megawatts because like i said it's but
i'm not sure it was
weather or it was the fact that that as
i mentioned earlier as we had
individual as we started restoring load
there was less megawatts on each feeder
that had occurred
uh when when the load those feeders were
originally turned off
and that that less load was a function
of you know
things being shut down less less
consumption and then also
there's some extent it was due to the
more of
less cold temperature so as a
combination
okay this is a follow-up from nbc news
uh
why did the board of directors list
disappear
from the urcot website looks like the
link to it is gone
and does ercot have a response to the
governor saying on
a local abc station that leadership
should resign
on the website issue
the publicly available information for
those board of directors members
was being used to send uh sometimes
harassing
uh communications
and threats were being made to the board
members
we were very concerned about both
employee and
board member safety basically because of
the things we've been receiving
over the past few days so
the thought was let's pull that contact
information down but i think on
reflection
as we after we did that i mean this was
something going on
you know sort of in the background
because it's certainly not related to
getting power back on the grid uh but
on reflection we figured that
information ought to be up there and i
think
i think we leslie do you know if we've
replaced it
back or not uh i i know that the
information will be back up before next
week so
i'll check that yeah yeah so it was a
it was a security safety idea
uh but i think as as people observed um
you know that's that's it was public
information uh
uh that uh has been on the website in
the past so we think it's it makes sense
to
go ahead and get that back up there
okay i think we've got time for sorry i
didn't
leave out your second part i think that
you know the the idea of changing the
governance changing the board of
directors
the the uh uh oversight of ercot
actually sort of the creation and
purpose and
uh what we're supposed to be doing all
of that is
reflected in texas statutes in texas law
and as uh the energy markets have
evolved as the expectations of ercot
have evolved and changed
that's addressed by the legislature and
then by the public utility commission
i think if there's dissatisfaction with
how
ercot's board governance process works
uh
it sounds like that will be part of the
review that comes after
uh we get the number one priority of
getting people's lights back on after
that's done
and we you know welcome that discussion
but it's a discussion that you know
however the
legislature resolves it that's what
we'll do um that's
that's how we operate because the
composition of our board is
is defined in statute and if the
legislature thinks that needs to change
then that's certainly something we'll
we'll follow
okay and a final question from the star
telegram
there's been policy debate about
renewable versus thermal energy sources
from texas
leaders in light of this weather event
what do you all think the texas
legislature should look at when it comes
to energy policy and sources
well again um the policy debate
uh is not one that we're focused on
right now
uh i'm sure you know this event uh
which called so much attention to the to
the energy to the electric system
uh is going to be discussed debated and
analyzed uh
starting next week the legislature is
going to start having hearings next week
about that
so i think there's you know there was a
robust debate about energy policy in a
lot of quarters
uh you know well before these events and
i think these events have really put a
sharp focus on them so i think you'll
see legislative debate about that
and you know again kind of back to
urcot's role
the state asks us to implement
state law and to implement measures to
make sure that the grid is reliable and
doesn't have a blackout
and if there are changes in what the
legislature wants ercot to do
as part of that that again you know we
need to follow the state statute because
that's
uh that's you know our governing
document when it comes down to it
okay well i think we are just about at
the top of the hour
so i am going to conclude this media
call but we will
continue to bring you updates uh later
in the day
and uh we appreciate you joining us and
thank you bill and thank you dan
i know you two are busy and tired and uh
we do appreciate you communicating with
the media
so thank you so much thank you all happy
to be here